just a few words quickly about the
struck
to be doing today and then we'll sort of
have a lot of slides prepared here maybe
about ten minutes or so I figured I'm
going to run through those really
quickly and give everyone a chance to
hopefully get the materials for the
course down download it or copy it off
the USB stick and also get boquete the
latest version zero point four point one
a bouquet installed as well and then I
figure I'll take a few minutes to take
some questions and then we'll dive into
the exercises so I'll explain the
structure of the the tarball the zip
file for the exercises once I'm done
with the slides so that said why don't
we go ahead and get started
okay so first a little bit about me just
in case anyone's curious so I work for
continuum analytics and I've been a
contributor to a couple of different
open source projects over the years
notably of course bouquet right now I'm
one of the major contributors to bouquet
I also spent some time on choco many
years ago and numpy I've got a few pull
requests in there as well so definitely
have experience working in a few
different domains financial engineering
Python mostly lately but C and C++ in
the back as well and my backgrounds in
physics and math so I think it's nice to
have that sort of ability to be
conversant in the specialized domain
when we're working with big data so
about continuum just a quick few words
as well most of us are in Austin Texas
although that's actually changing we
have a lot of folks all over the world
now including here in London and in
Germany and in Spain so it's exciting to
be a part of a small growing company
we're definitely interested in
scientific and high-performance
computing but also in bridging the gap
between big data and data scientists and
data analysts and domain experts that
want to be able to work with that data
so we're trying to build an entire
platform of tools many of which are open
source to to bridge that gap and one of
those tools is bouquet okay so what's
going so again interactive browser-based
visualization for big data driven from
Python and others that and others is
actually a nice point to emphasize now
we just had contributed Scala bindings
for bouquet so I'll explain the
architecture of bouquet here in just a
minute but it's basically the idea is we
can have bindings for bouquet from a lot
of languages not just Python and so I'd
like to see that encouraged as as time
goes on any case just so you know the
full information the documentation
everything is available at bouquet PI
data or
so the idea behind bouquet is that we
can do interactive visualizations in the
browser we can create plots we can
create all kinds of novel and
interesting visualizations from Python
without having to worry about JavaScript
by having to muck around in JavaScript
and in addition to this we'd like to
have you know seamless interoperability
with the ipython notebook the ability to
create static HTML pages that contain
our plots and the ability to serve data
with a server so the your plot can be
connected to a live data source that's
updating and the plot reaction so that's
really all of the sort of major facets
you know a bouquet sort of put together
one of the or some of the you know again
important features about bouquet is that
it's a language base where it's a
library it's not some GUI tool it's not
some sort of canned tool it has a really
fixed set of options it's a very
expressive library it has tight
composable set of abstractions at a low
level and then above that we're building
a very high level sort of interface
geared toward ease of use and so the
idea there being that you know where we
can do something sensible and
intelligent we should do that
automatically but where that can't be
done we can express an expose capability
at the low level so that's really what
we want to do most of all of course
we're also interested in our
interactivity the ability to have all
kinds of tools that can interrogate your
data hover tools you know tools for
panning and zooming and inspecting your
data I included in that is of course if
you're moving around in your data you
want to be able to access large datasets
so pipe bouquets really geared towards
large data sets as well we're just now
adding some fantastic features for down
sampling and doing abstract rendering on
very large data set so that you can have
interactive performance on large data
sets ok so those are some of the nice
nice features of bouquet a couple of
notes about the implementation before we
sort of dive into things so it's not
based on d3 to get that question quite a
bit for performance reasons the ability
to plot perhaps a hundred thousand
points or several hundred thousand
points at a time we built from the
ground up in html5 canvas library html5
canvas is very extremely performant I
was honestly a little bit surprised when
I came to it I had not done
works work on the canvas up to this
point and it was really gratifying to
use because of this we can definitely
handle sort of streaming data real-time
data I'll show off an example a little
bit later as well and again the fact
that we have these sort of low-level
composable abstractions means that we
can create very novel and interesting
visualizations I'll show a couple of
examples of those as well
and sort of see one here this is you
know a visualization we created really
at the bottom to create to show off
capability it's a reproduction of a
chart made by a guy named Burton about
50 years ago to demonstrate the efficacy
of different antibiotics and so he did
something interesting that I might take
issue with but which is to say that he
has an inverted radial axis which I've
never seen in a plot before right so he
was trying to show which antibiotic was
most effective so he wanted the longer
bars to represent smaller concentrations
of antibiotics required so he inverted
that but we just you know we want to
reproduce this plot just to show what
you can do with bouquet and so that was
one of the things we did and we'll see
some other kinds of novel plots in this
tutorial as well again the main thing
though is that to do all these plots you
don't have to interact with JavaScript
you can really drive all this directly
from Python and we'll see just how to do
that today a couple of key concepts for
bouquet in terms of the high level
interface and just to be clear we're
going to talk about the high level
plotting interface that I mentioned
today right so there is a very low level
interface that sort of mirrors the
JavaScript library quite closely and
lets you do very you know very
expressive things but there's a higher
level interface on top of that and
that's we're going to be covering today
in this tutorial at that level really
everything on a plot element is
represented by a glyph some visual
element that you can scatter across the
screen and in a certain sense all
bouquet plots or scatter plots so we
take a lot of inspiration from for
instance Leland wilkinson's grammar of
graphics right so the idea is that for
every visual element you should really
be able to tie the properties of that
visual element to data or a series of
data so for instance if you want to
scatter not just a bunch of circles or
markers you might want to scatter a
bunch of polygons and so you can have a
vector of polygon data and you
immediately scatter all those things you
might want to set the visual properties
at each of those polygons independently
and so you can tie the visual properties
of those polygons to some other set of
data that gets mapped automatically into
a color space and so that's sort of one
of the key
abstracts of Boca just going to take a
look at a couple of interesting plots
that people have contributed recently
this was actually sup contributed to
Boca is a PR someone created this
interesting plot and wanted to share it
with us so this is the sort of thing you
can do and you can get an idea sort of
the simplicity of the code to do this
right I mean so I've set our has been
set on this plot of a number of visual
elements that's actually the bulk of
these parameters supplied to the circle
and the text functions here but really
we have some data that describes our you
know our periodic table of elements and
we can simply map that to circles map
that to texts we can set a few
parameters for the you know the styling
of our plot and we're actually
continually making that easier to do as
well and then we show the pot and it
shows up and so the idea is to get to
make very simple interface at the top
level they can handle the 90% case and
do what you want and do very flexible
things but still to provide a low-level
interface when you need it another pot
this is an example of an integrated
vector field right so we want to have
this you know streamlines sorry the yeah
the streamlines of the vector field
displayed here and so this is another
example I mentioned how all the glyphs
in boquete can be vectorized so for
instance you could have circles vector
eyes over some set of data or squares or
rectangles or polygons you could have
for instance lines themselves you could
have a vector of line data where each
elements in the vector is really a set
of points for a line and you can splat
that very easily onto the screen using
the multi-line lifts right so multi-line
here takes a list of lists of points and
a sequence of sequence of Y points and
then it simply plots all of the things
there so it's a very again simple
high-level interface for expressing
these kind of vectorized data quantities
another example of that is with the
patches patches glyph here again we
might want to have several polygons and
so here we can have a simple corp left
simply fall out right so we have a
vector of you know X polygon positions
and a vector of Y polygon positions and
then we have a vector of colors that we
want to associate with those and we
simply pass all of those vectorize
quantities into the package glyph and
voila out pops a nice corpus with sort
of very little minimal effort and indeed
all of these properties things like the
line color line width even things like
the line dashing you can
actually vectorize all of those things
quite quite nicely and quite naturally
so again taking those ideas from grammar
of graphics last example here again just
some quads in case you want to do a
histogram we all like to see histograms
so this is a nice example of histogram
with an ideal distribution and
cumulative distribution shown as well
and again it's just very simple
high-level interface and this is what
what we're going to be talking about
today without really too much
explanation just a couple of
demonstrations of capability some of the
things we're just added very recently
actually really in preparation for this
talk we want to be able to have nice
examples and exercises for you guys to
do or some categorical access support so
here you can see for instance
reproduction of Mike Bostock fantastic
lamia's occurrences plot and you know
mine looks a little bit different but
you can see it's the same exact idea
right so we have this sort of very large
categorical axes on each side and we
sort of color the cells depending on the
number of Co occurrences of each
characters from lamia's so that's
fantastic we can also add a nice hover
tool to this so we can actually
interrogate each cell in this plot and
get for instance more information that
might be sword in our data sources
things like stack plots here's that
another vector field example over there
for instance now we have a basically a
quiver plot and this is again a
vectorized glyph we have the idea of
segments we simply pass in the quiver
coordinates as vectors of vectors of
data to the segment glyph and all of
those segments simply show up where they
should map example another one again
vectorize shapes so again really comes
back to that grammar of graphics type
idea some more categorical heat maps
again this is a chart reproduced from
New York Times us unemployment 1948 to
2013 or to the present and so again this
is can be outfitted with a in fact you
guys will work on the spot can be
outfitted with a hover tool right so you
can add whatever additional metadata for
each one of these categorical pairings
that you want and your hover tool can
express that and expose that data and
show it to your users certainly image
spots come up as well so you can do
things like rgba images that you color
map yourself you can also ship off
scaler image data tube okay to the
client side to be color maps in the
browser will also work fine charts like
box plots you can construct those by
hand now we're definitely to be adding
some schematic interfaces that sort of
generate common types of plots Violin
plots box plots sort of
in an automated fashion not too much
work to do just a matter of getting it
done but certainly you can create this
the capability there exists now to
create of course very nice and
attractive looking box plots and violin
plots and finally this last example here
in the bottom this was actually created
with bouquet as well and so this is
really akin to a categorical heat map
right this is actually just a couple of
categories for the group in the period
and we've reproduced the entire periodic
table we're able to look you know
position those labels and additional
information for the periodic table
directly using bouquet and we'll see
this example in the exercises as well if
you get to get that far and and then
also you can have a hover tool again so
you can interrogate even more properties
for each element exposed to that hover
tool okay so that's sort of the current
capability is sort of where bouquets
adding this zero point four point one
release
we're definitely planning on having
other release a major release in 0.5 and
about I'd say end of April somewhere
around that timeframe just a couple of
words about what you can look forward to
in that in that release one is a concept
of abstract rendering so bouquet is
supported in part by a DARPA grant for
the X data program and it's very
fortunate we were going to write bouquet
anyway but this has certainly allowed us
to accelerate the development quite a
bit one of our co collaborators on this
grant is a researcher at the university
of chicago joseph cottom who has worked
on a concept called abstract rendering
he's actually the original stencil
author essential paper author so
abstract rendering is effectively a very
intelligent way to downsample your data
it renders the data to an abstract
canvas but when it does so it collects
statistical information about how many
times each pixel was hit and by what
elements and so then you can actually
form a distribution of where your data
hits the canvas and so then instead of
doing for instance a constant you know
alpha mapping to try to handle over
plotting you can actually do effectively
HDR high dynamic range or data shading
you can apply a different alpha in one
reason where the data is still
interesting but low and a much lower
alpha and a reason where they data where
the data is stacked up very high and so
you can try to extract again the most
information from your data as possible
and this will scale up to many many
millions of points very large data sets
also going to be working on a better
constraint space-based layout system for
having very intelligent way
is to attach annotations things like
legends to your plot and also to layout
grid plots a nice sort of grid bag type
abstraction a little bit easier than
dealing with the CSS model least in my
opinion more tools we have several neat
tools you can use to interact with
bouquet plots now we have a lot more
planned and also just some improvements
in general to our tool infrastructure
and map pot Lib compatibility we have a
fair chunk of that done already dummy
and Avila who is a fantastic contributor
to the ipython world has come on board
he's helping us out with this lately and
so I think he just finished up the patch
collection from from matplotlib and so
we're looking to get enough out of this
really to drive for instance pandas
ggplot and seaboard plots to the browser
from bouquet right so that's I think
will be a fantastic thing and so
matplotlib compatibility is a big big
goal for us and that's ongoing work I
also mentioned language bindings at the
beginning you know you can drive these
interactions and these visualizations
from Python but we'd love to be able to
drive them from not just Python but
Scala at R and Ruby and MATLAB or Excel
integration there's all kinds of
possibilities so a word maybe about the
architecture bouquet actually so bouquet
is actually two pieces it's a browser
based JavaScript library it's a reactive
scene graph library that accepts as its
input declarative descriptive you know
pieces of JSON that describe your plot
as well as the data and so as it gets
this data it basically evaluates or
parses or you know runs these
descriptions and generates the plot and
as the data updates the plot also reacts
to that and updates as well and so that
browser part is called bouquet J s and
its really a standalone piece you can
use bouquet J s right now in a
JavaScript applications without any
Python at all and I can show off a few
examples of bouquet giasses usage as a
pure JavaScript library and so anything
that can generate these declarative you
know Jason snippets that describe your
plot can certainly drive lots to Boca
J's so right now we're focused on Python
that's sort of our our main interests
and use cases lie but there's no reason
you couldn't have any language in
principle drive plots from cocaine so
we're definitely interested in working
on new language bindings attracting
contributors to work on new language
bindings to scratch whatever age they
have and so that's ongoing work as well
and finally some widget interactors and
plugins so we're elect the idea of being
able to build basically applications
centered around bouquet plot so for
instance you might have you know drop
downs and sliders and all kinds of
widgets that you can manipulate to
change the contents of your plot or to
slice through data sources and whatnot
remote data sources so that's again
what's coming soon another thing not to
forget that's coming soon is increased
usability improvements I think bouquets
had a pretty good state but obviously
the best way to improve the usability of
your you know your to love your library
is to really banging on other people's
problems and to let other people really
hammer at it until it's you know smooth
down to something that works really well
for everyone so I think we'll probably
see today in the course of the exercises
a few things there may be a little bit
clunkier than they ought to be but
hopefully through feedback from folks
like you we'll get a lot of really
fantastic information not be trapped in
our sort of development bubble and be
able to improve the usability even more
and so that's definitely an important
goal of mine and important goal of
Peters and all of us on the team working
on cocaine okay so for more information
in contributing you know there's
obviously the github repos the bouquets
on github and joseph Katims abstract
rendering work is also there the
integration for that's a little bit slow
I think he developed it in closure so
we're sort of in the process of porting
it to Python you can see some instant
videos voce workshop that I think Peter
gave and also talked I think that Peter
gave about Python the future of the
future of data analysis and of course
some blogs right so there's lots of
different blogs in the continuum site
describing the evolution and features
that are in Boca so all of these links
by the way are in the PDF that is inside
the tutorial material that you
downloaded or you copied off the USB
stick so that has your again your copy
of the PDF and it also has the the
exercises web page and we'll get to that
in a second just a quick recap the
beginning in case anyone popped in late
and needs to get a hold of the data
files we leave that up just for a minute
this is the location of the tutorial
material so again in there you'll find a
copy of this PDF for the slides but
you'll also find an index dot HTML file
that contains a nice Fink's document
that has all the exercises we're going
to be doing I think I made way too many
exercises for the length of his class so
that's I don't know that's good news
right so that means you don't need me
you can keep going after this class is
over and find any particular exercises
that seem interesting to you and work
so I guess let's take a few minutes and
make sure everyone's sort of setup that
you know everyone is going to be trying
to work the exercises is set up with an
installation that has bouquet that has a
you know a copy of the tutorial
materials and we'll just say you know
maybe five minutes or so and let me go
ahead and show what is inside the
tutorial material tarball and we can get
a get a feel for what's there so again
either have the tarball or the zip file
go ahead and just uncompress that
somewhere somewhere handy and open this
up on my desktop and then inside the
HTML folder there is an index.html and
so this is our tutorial material so
again there is some information actually
here under installation so that's one
place you can look for information on
installing boquete in case you're having
any difficulties that has some
additional information there's some
introduction talk a little bit about
what's included and what's not include
let me actually go over that right quick
so again the main thrust of this
tutorial is in the high-level interface
right you know sort of the very simple
plotting interface that handles many
many cases but isn't at the lowest
levels of Boquete some things we are
going to be really talking about in this
tutorial there map pot live
compatibility again that work is ongoing
we're not I talked about that low-level
interface I'm not going to talk about
Bocage is explicitly as a standalone
library although I will probably demo
something here at the end just to show
it off and we're also not talking about
the server so right now the server does
use Redis which makes it a bit
problematic to run on Windows and we're
working actively to sort of reduce that
dependency and make the book a server
work very easily on Windows but just
because of those issues we decided to
leave it out of the tutorial and so
we're not talking about that can see the
server is used for a number of things we
can use it for data persistence if we
want to host spots you know in a
persistent way that people can access if
we want to do this streaming and
updating of data if we want to do this
intelligent down sampling all that is
sort of relies on the bouquet server so
really fantastic capability but we'll
have to save those for another tutorial
another day also sharing an embedding
and animated plot so we'll I might show
some examples but will will not have
time for that okay so a couple of notes
also about the exercise let me just show
you what those look like so if you go
into for instance basic exercises this
is the first exercise drawing lines
so what you have is a incomplete script
and throughout the script there are some
comments annotated with this you know
start with this word exercise and here
in in the in the document I have those
all highlighted in yellow so you can see
them and this is places where you need
to fill in some portion of the code and
hopefully typically it's something that
is maybe a tweak of something you've
seen before so for instance you want to
reproduce another line so you're going
to take the line that's above and modify
that a little bit so hopefully it's an
incremental learning process for
everyone here so that's what they look
like you can also find the actual script
the incomplete exercise script at this
location for instance scripts / lines
pie so if for instance you want to open
that up and your editor to do your work
and then finally at the bottom of every
exercise there is a solution as well so
you can use that to compare to your work
and also see a live plot so here for
instance take a second to load we can
see live versions of all the plots so
this actually creates several plots and
you can interact with all of these you
know just however you need to use the
tools all of that works fine use the
resize tool we can make that bigger or
smaller so anyway you can see that and
then down below the plots is the actual
solution that I came up with so you can
compare that to your work of course feel
free to ask me questions as you're
working I think I figure I'll take a few
minutes per exercise and then I'll maybe
talk about it briefly and then we'll
move on to the next exercise so again
kind of a fast pace but it give you guys
a chance to sort of work and ask
questions of me while you're working and
then we can discuss it and move on so as
you can see there are quite a number of
exercises
I think there's five or six exercises
under basic I so I have a bunch of basic
exercises then I have what I call
topical exercises which really deal with
specific types of plots that you might
be interested in doing for instance time
series histograms box plots heat maps
and bar charts so if yours did one of
those topics this I sort of see is more
of a free-for-all so if you're
interested one of these topics please do
feel free to just jump in and and try
one of those after the the basic
exercises and then finally a few
advanced exercise as well for instance
that lame is Rob co-occurrence charts
and also the periodic table so again
we're not there's no way we're going to
make it through all of this but that's
okay now you have this here to take with
you and to work on which
seemed interesting or useful to you and
to learn how to do them so okay so any
more questions any more problems getting
things installed
are you guys having any more success
over here over on the left you're able
to find the newest version of okay yet
okay all right so if anyone has any
problems definitely just raise your hand
sort of holler out I'll come take a look
I think there's someone over here that's
still trying to install so I'm gonna go
take a look at them but in the meantime
why don't you guys go ahead and start on
basic exercise number one drawing lines
so I can describe a little bit about the
sort of the overall structure of this
plot and then let you guys go so here
just for simplicity I've gone ahead and
from você plotting import star normally
you might want to import just the things
you want to use but for simplicity I've
done that we also need something called
the range one day we want to be able to
set the range explicitly on our plot so
I've imported that as well and typically
these are arranged in terms of creating
or reading some data at the top so we
can see here that I'm creating some data
I'm creating a couple of different numpy
arrays I'm converting those radial
coordinates into x and y coordinates and
then we're going to plot them and so
here's again where you see what happens
so I've tried to intersperse comments
that describe what each of these things
does and then later on the future you'll
probably be asked to do some of those
things yourself
so likes it please let me know if you
have any questions we'll take just a
couple of minutes here and I'll get this
exercise working we'll talk about the
solution maybe in just maybe a couple
minutes
quick thing I want to mention to you
guys so since some folks do want to work
on the notebook and that's fantastic let
me go ahead and show you one change
you'll need to make to these scripts to
use them I had hope to have a notebook
content ready for this class but I just
didn't make it in time so the next the
next class we'll get some notebooks
pretty ready to go so there's one change
need to make in order to use the
notebook to these so let me go ahead and
make sure and let me start the ipython
notebook
okay so let me create a new notebook so
here I'm going to for instance from poke
a dot plotting import star so there's a
line output underscore file in the
examples in scripts and what this does
is it tells bouquet I want to generate a
static HTML file and I want you to write
this file to disk whenever I tell you to
show the plot if we want to use the
notebook you need to change those lines
to output underscore notebook and it
should say configuring embedded bulk ajs
mode and then for instance we can do
something like line of 1 2 3 & 4 6 7 and
that doesn't actually show the bots
although a new feature that's being
added is to auto show the plots when you
execute a cell then we want to issue
that show command and our plot just
shows up embedded and again all the
interactive tools that we've decided or
chosen to add or available so we can Pan
the tool around we can of course zoom it
sorry just like wheel zoom we know we
can and reset the view we can resize the
plot all of that all that's available so
the only so again the major change there
is if you want to use the notebook for
these examples that's great I apologize
for not having notebooks ready to go for
the for the scripts but I just changed
the output underscore file line to
output underscore notebook and you
should be good to go
also if you've already tried to run it
without put file in the notebook you
probably want to go and restart your
kernel and try to rerun those because
you know it does it does store that you
know when you execute these commands the
Jas gets orders bar the notebook and
you'll need to flush that out so just
just go ahead and restart your kernel if
you've already run output underscore
file yeah sure
Chrome there we go
and this is actually a good litmus test
so if you're just installing Bokan you
want to make sure it works this is the
kind of bot you know you can just try to
throw up and make sure this works if
this doesn't work we need to come take a
look at you know what might need to be
installed or what's missing but this
should definitely work you know output
underscore file or output underscore
notebook in the notebook should be
should be just fine
yeah oh can you scroll up so you scroll
up of it right so have you already
filled in everything so oh so well part
of its you know so that exercise is
still left and the figure is still left
and so so yeah so these are the plots
that you need to fill in yeah so there's
some portions for you to find if you
want to please you know navigate over to
the solution I'll show you what the
missing lines are so for instance if I
go over here to if I go over here to
basically exercise if I scroll the
bottom you can see see the solution and
so it'll bring up all the plots which is
great and we can interact with those but
then you can also see under the lines
that are marked exercise what I had to
put in you know what's the the sort of
line you need to put in to make that pot
actually work so just to be clear all of
those things under scripts are
incomplete right there they're exercises
for you to complete and you try to fill
in the missing bits and again please
refer to the solution to sort of help
you along with that or ask me questions
as well I figure we'll take just another
I don't know maybe a couple of minutes
two minutes here and then we'll we'll
sort of talk about this and then move on
so if you're having issues let me come
take a look so here I'm going to go
ahead and paste the solution in a new
notebook and we'll sort of see the kind
of change we need to make something like
a new notebook and I will just paste
that in there wholesale and I will
change output file to output notebook
hit shift enter and so yah plots
definitely coming out now note that I've
done this all in one cell so current
limitation here is that you really only
can get one plot sort of per cell and so
again we're we're improving our ipython
notebook integration again dummy and
avila is really helping us out with that
he's the perfect person to be helping
with that so expect some new sort of
improvements in in the near future for
ipython notebook integration okay so
yeah I was just saying let's go ahead
and move on a little bit I'll talk about
this and then we'll move on and then
folks that have specific trouble I'm
happy to talk about things you know
throughout PI data on here and available
the notebook integration works pretty
well but I think it does need a little
bit more polishing again we have some
great folks working on that so all right
but let's take a look at the actual
solution here so what did I go ahead and
change so we were asked to reproduce
this plot above so we created a line
here right we passed in the X&Y
coordinates for this Archimedean spiral
we gave it a color we can set things
like the line width the title of the
plot and a legend as well and we would
plot the when the plot shows up all of
those things are reflected in the plot
so we were tasked with reproducing this
plot for one of the other spirals so
it's a very simple change here to simply
use the different set of data right so
it's just to give you a little practice
you know typing in and using some of
these different renderers the next thing
we were asked to do was to plot all of
these spirals on the same plot so in
order to do that we actually have to
issue what's called the hold command so
by default every time you call one of
these renderers circle or square or any
of these line any of these renderers
that creates a new figure so if you want
to actually have everything show up on
one plot you have to call the hold
command and then you ask it for a
completely new fixture figure so doing
that all of our commands subsequent to
that are going to show up on one plot so
we can simply have the same line
commands we had above for all for all
four different Archimedean are all four
different spirals and now we should see
all of those on one plot
and if we see that we see that well it's
not quite great right because some of
the spirals expand out greatly you don't
really have much detail so it'd be nice
if we could actually set the range of
this pot explicitly here's an area where
I think it might be a little clunky but
we're going to improve this as well you
have to use one of those range range 1d
objects to set that to set that range so
you can see down here at the bottom
there's an X range parameter and a wide
range parameter and I pass it in one of
those range 1ds that has a start and an
end and so I've now set my plot bounds
to minus 10 to 10 in both directions and
that's what this last plot has so we can
get a little bit more detailed zoomed in
view of those so any questions about
this sort of you know interface
architecture sort of before we move on
to the next example yes
okay great great question yeah so a
question is what what are all the colors
so the the bouquet top hydatid organ or
it has a pretty extensive documentation
at this point but just to answer that
particular question briefly the colors
you can use are any of the 147 named CSS
colors any hex color starting with a
pound and I think RGB a tuples also work
as well but yeah question I'm sorry oh
these ones yeah absolutely so for
instance if I want to use the Box zoom I
just hit box zoom and now I can zoom
into whatever reasons you know on the
plot that I'd like to see there's a
reset button that will reset the view to
its original parameters there's a resize
button that lets me resize and drag
we're gonna make that a nice hot corner
a little bit better but there's also
things like a preview save tool that
allow us to save off copy so is that the
question yes yes so it's fairly
simplistic right now right now there is
a tools parameter we'll see that in a
bit but you supply a list of tool names
as strings to this tools parameter and
you can tell it exactly which buttons
you want sorry I misunderstood your
question but yes okay so we definitely
bootstrap dot CSS and I'm not as
familiar with the the usage of that
particular aspect of okay but I do
believe we do use bootstrap pretty
heavily so my answer is probably yes now
I thought part of that should have been
included in book they complete you know
combined bulk ajs that's been built
together but yeah we do bootstrap okay
alright so let's go ahead and move on to
the next example
I want to take a look so now we have
scattering points so the idea is we want
to be able to create different kinds of
scatter plots that show for instance
different markers you know circles
squares whatever we want to do so let me
go ahead and show you the solution just
so you can see what the output is sort
of supposed to look like
here we're continuing on with that data
from the Archimedean spiral and we're
simply plotting different different
versions of so the data is not important
you know you can plot whatever data
you've got but this is just it really
expose how you would plot that data so
you should get three plots that look
quite a bit different and then a plot
here at the end that shows off how you
can sort of really vectorize these
plots over all kinds of different
attributes like the radius and the color
all at once so I will go back here and
so displaying images again there are
some exercise sections so again we want
to add a line that outputs the static
HTML file here we have an image command
we want to fill in
OOP sorry I'm on the wrong one here we
go here we have a scatterplot we want to
go ahead and fill in some you know
different values here try setting
different marker types try setting the
tools on this first renderer creating
new figures that's what you saw on the
last plot so now you get to try to do
that yourself so yeah so anyway I'll let
you guys loose symbol again we'll spend
maybe five ten minutes on this and I'll
take a look I only hold twice that might
be an issue you're having I think there
is a bug work we called hold twice it
sort of screws things up so you guys
interesting problems if you check and
see that you're not calling that hold
function twice in the same cell if you
are that might be what's causing your
problem I think there is a known issue
there that's going to be resolved
yes yes yeah so there's an idea of a
session basically that contains all the
objects you want to and somehow it's not
finding that session but again it could
also be some versioning issues I mean I
mean I haven't had any issues running
this one this is ipython notebook 1.1 I
think is what I'm running here okay zero
point four point one so it's a matter of
you know I do want to get the body so I
do want to take a look some of you guys
individually if you have time and you
want to look at it we can we could sort
of get to the bottom of it but there's
definitely an issue to be filed there
but in the meantime I would suggest
again I definitely tested all of these
scripts as Python scripts so if you just
try them as Python scripts you know open
them in your text editor and run them
that should work just fine other
questions oh you want a new chart in the
notebook yeah so again if you if you
just have a show here in the notebook
right now there's a limitation it's only
going to show the last plot so really
what you just need to do is split this
up into multiple cells that have oh
that's where you want to use this hold
command right so the hold command will
tell it I want all of the output to go
on to a single plot all the following
output right so you issue that before
whatever renderers you want to run to
combine them onto a single plot
so here I'll change this one
yeah won't be the last one yeah so I
think I think that is actually bug I
think if you hit hold twice there's a
bug where it does screw things up and so
I'm guessing what happens if you
re-evaluate the cell you're evaluating
hold a second time so my suggestion if
you do want to use the notebook break
this code up a little bit more put the
hold in its own cell and only execute
that once and then you can execute the
other code sort of as many times as you
want to so again I think we haven't
covered a little bug so I think that
might be the issue now that I think
about it all right so any questions
about this exercise before I sort of
discuss the solution just a little bit I
think I'm actually getting kind of close
to time here I'm going to show at the
end time is yeah it's any questions
first then we sort of mentioned the
solution okay so what do we have to
change here so again in this exercise
you know asked it to make a static
output so I added output file scattered
at HTML we're also asked to set the
range 1d object right so we want to go
ahead and create a range 1d object and
we want to reuse these so this will
actually be something interesting let's
see what happens if we reuse range
objects in between plots here we go
ahead and add a few more scatter renders
just like we had in the previous
exercise and then finally create a new
figure and then down here at the bottom
we also have our circle render so what
happens when we share these ranges
between plots what happens is we
automatically get linked sort of
brushing and panning all together right
so if I scroll and zoom this plot the
other plots scroll and zoom as well so
right so that's what happens if we share
these ranges in between plots is we sort
of get this linked panning and link
zooming along for the ride so that's one
way to affect that okay all right so any
questions about that exercise before we
move on ok
so I think I'm just going to show this
displaying image is sort of as a quick
demo and then we might move on to
styling your plot so I think that might
be a little bit more interesting so
let's take a look at that so here if I
go to displaying images the kind of
things we can do are for instance to
either display scalar images that we
color map ourselves that's what this
Mandelbrot set is or we can create rgba
images out of data explicitly and send
over the RGB a data and so we can take a
look at some of the functions of this
you know of this the script and we can
see that we need to call the image
renderer right and so the image renderer
is interesting as well just like you
know a circle you can scatter that
across a bunch of points and display a
bunch of points the images you can also
scatter a bunch of images all at once
right so this actually tastes a list of
image and a list of x and y coordinates
and a list of whit's and heights for the
images and you can splat many images at
once and so there's actually a nice
example of this being used for a little
spectrogram demo that I can show off in
a bit where I don't want to have to
recolor map an entire 2,000 by 1000
pixel buffer but I don't mind color
mapping just a little chunk and so I can
have several images that I can work on
simultaneously so that's a very nice
feature again all of this stuff is sort
of built around this idea of operations
visual operations being vectorized over
data again we create a figure that works
fine but again we can also create rgba
data so here I just create some RGB a
actual color data and now I call the
image RGB a glyph and it's also
vectorized just like the image glyph
again I give it the image in this case I
give it a sequence of one image along
with some coordinates to display I can
set some tools and at the top you can
see this is the RGB a image this pot
it's just the square of sort of colors
and then this was our Mandelbrot set
that we created as well so that's sort
of the gist of images all right great so
styling your pot so let's go and take a
look at styling your plot so this is
sort of how can we sort of manipulate
what our plots look like so there's only
a couple of things to do in this again
if you the safest route I think is to
try to run it a script if you do want to
try it in the notebook I would recommend
splitting it up into some multiple cells
because there are problems with
reissuing that hold command it seems to
screw things up but seems to be a known
issue so I would split
up a little bit maybe execute the the
output line in its own cell but also
execute if you execute a hold command
execute that in its own cell as well but
here what we want to do is we want to
add some parameters to our patches call
that plays with things like the line
color the line alpha the dashing just
takes a sequence of integers to
represent the dash structure the
background fill of the plot and then we
can also see how we can exit how we can
modify all the properties of for
instance the axes right so if we want to
change the line color the line width the
dashing of the axis or the ticks if we
want to change the standoff for the
ticks or the labels or the orientation
of the labels we have a control over all
of that and so you can see that down
here at the bottom basically you can
just replace the comments here after
each line with your own values and see
how things look so just as an example
you can take a look at my solution here
you can see I've changed the background
color and the axes colors and widths
independently orientated the orientated
the labels a bit down there at the
bottom for easier reading and their font
size as well so anyway play around with
that for a few minutes and we'll take a
look at it in just a bit for sure you
want to remove which one all of them
sure so you can do something like this
so these successors here like axis and x
axis axis gives you all of the axes as a
sequence but it also returns an object
that lets you sort of apply property
changes to all of them right so if axis
returns one or two or four axes setting
dot major-label text font size will
affect all of them right so it's a nice
sort of list like object it allows you
to sort of propagate those changes but
if you want to have the colors if you
want to get rid of a line the easiest
way to do that is to set the color equal
to none so if here for instance I can
say axis axis that line color equals
none looks like that's already there
actually
try changing that to something else
right quick
that's interesting okay
never actually try to get rid of the
actually so there may be able issue
there as well but definitely know that
work for like the gridline so for
instance here if I call y grid equals
none and run it that gets rid of my Y
grade for instance it looks like for
some reason it's not doing if the axis
and I might have to poke into why that
could be but typically setting the color
it might just be I have the name of the
property wrong there I thought it would
be access line color
oh I know it's oh right right right so
there's also a optional border outline
and that I'm not sure you can get rid of
just right now it'd be an easy change to
add that and so we might have a quick
release that would do that but so that
that gets rid of the access but there's
still this outline underneath it and so
for instance we could do you see if this
works
that certainly would work right right so
let's try that outline line color it's
cried a couple different ways and so
it's interesting is I mean this is the
sort of thing you can definitely do from
the JavaScript occasionally there's a
you know maybe an issue in translation
and so we're still hammering out some of
the kinks okay that didn't get rid of it
let's try setting it to light gray and
see if that
okay I have to poke around it there's
either a small bug there or I've
forgotten the right to property name but
that's definitely possible to Java
scripts I've done it before okay so
let's take a look at the solution for
this guy and see where we're at too many
tabs open now
close some of these guys okay so if we
take a look at a solution that I came up
with again I just set a bunch of these
parameters you can set the colors to
anything like those names CSS colors or
hex values if you like again the grid
line widths are just numbers the font
size are things like you know string
values of sizes and points or EMS or
pixels accepted values for the style
there are things like bold italic and
normal so again you have access to all
of these properties there's a fairly
regimented kind of naming scheme we'll
probably try to add some easier way to
configure these like for instance
through a style sheet kind of a
mechanism so you can specify it once and
sort of theme entire sets of plots but
that's a feature that will probably be
out in the next couple of releases and
again here for my actual renderer I
added things like line color you know
and changed all those things up
background fill color border fill as
well so we have you know the ability
sort of make our plots look lots of good
interesting ways all right I think we
might have time for one last exercise
like I said I developed way too much
content for this 80 minute course but
let's go and take a look at it cuz I
think the hover tool is kind of cool so
this last exercise here is about adding
a hover tool to your data so here it is
it's not too long there's a couple of -
dues we need to define some data here
that we want to be able to display we
need to add a static HTML output I can
even leave that optional part off or you
want to try it that's fine but that's to
use a text renderer to add text labels
as well or to try things beside circles
but I'd leave it as is to start and then
we need to configure this this hover
tool so note that the hover tool
currently takes pairs of sort of keys
and values right so that the key is what
you want the display to be on the hover
tool on the screen and then the value is
sort of a key to look up in the data
source so for instance if I want to
display the X&Y coordinates I can do a
dollar x dollar Y or sort of the known
X&Y coordinates if I want to look up you
know a particular value from the data
source I can use like at foo so I'm
adding some columns here foo to my data
source I can say at foo and I'll show me
the value of foo under the cursor is
what I would get and so configure that a
little bit and then we'll take a look
again this is
what the output should look like and if
we turn on the hover tool we can see
that it shows you know I've configured
mine to show the index which is just the
index into the data source data the X&Y
position the current radius of the
circle that's underneath it
what fill color is there along with a
little swatch of color and then I added
some different data for foo and bars so
I added two sequences of data for foo
and bar the same number of elements as
my other data data sequences and so now
I can pull those out as well and show
them in the hover tool as well a little
bit later on we're going to add some
capability to have arbitrary sort of
templates to go in I mean this is sort
of a fairly simplistic hover tool right
now but it's not going to be too much
effort to extend this to have much more
interesting sort of hover tools but this
should give you an idea of sort of
what's available there
and while you guys are working I know
there's some other folks that don't if
you don't have a computer or working on
that I can show off a couple of demos I
think we're I think we're getting pretty
close to time is at 4:40 I think at the
end time yeah so let me show off just a
couple of demos my guys are working on
that so one is again using Bo KJ s as
just a pure JavaScript library so this
is a nice little example of a
spectrogram so there's actually a python
class server that's reading audio data
from my microphone and sending it or
making it available through a rest call
and this JavaScript application is
polling that as you know as often as it
can to update the data and you can see
that it updates you know with this I can
change things like the gain I can change
the frequency range that I want to
display if I want to zoom in on some of
the lower frequencies so here this is
just a rolling rolling FFT sort of
waterfall plot this plot here lower that
down whoop
hit pause I'm not sure what I did there
I love that Oh interesting
I've never seen it do that before Oh
wonders of live demos I've actually
shown this quite a bit but never might
be that my Python server crashed let's
restart the Python server very strange
okay sure what I did there anyway so
this obviously is the power domain here
and down below sorry that's the
frequency domain and down here we can
just see the actual power domain and
here this is a nice goofy little
equalizer we've just wrapped around a
circle just as sort of show that we can
do it so that's an example again of
using Bocage as purely as a JavaScript
library that's certainly something you
can do today coming up in the future
again we talked about intelligent sort
of down sampling this is a prototype you
goshi one of my colleagues developed for
a client that we work with and so this
is about two million data points that
and linked sort of brushing and what you
can actually do is zoom in on it pan
around and you'll actually see the
resolution of the data change right it's
actually doing down sampling on the fly
so it's really you know two million pots
per series we can have really fast
interactive sort of updates to that
another example this one's a little bit
another prototype this is a four
gigabytes of
temperature data it's a 3d cube of data
ocean temperatures you can slide things
around to see for instance at this you
know at the line of zero longitude I can
see the vertical slice through and I can
see that update or I can see for
instance if I change the latitude I can
see that update as well but more than
that I can also zoom in right so if i
zoom into an area and see it's pretty
rough but then it successively filters
and so we're just getting started with
this you know that's a little bit I
would say not necessarily acceptable
performance but we're getting there and
so the idea is to be able to do this
kind of drill down into large data sets
very natively and without much issue so
that's coming I think a lot of this will
be in the next 0.5 release at the end of
April so look for that again pan around
all sorts of stuff over here and it
should update the data eventually we can
reset the view anyway all kinds of fun
stuff I see no reason why this can't
easily scale to hundreds of gigabytes
because actually our bottleneck right
now is the data transfer we just did
sort of the most naive simple thing that
you could imagine
and so the encoding and decoding and to
and from Jason actually is quite
expensive so we need to find a more
efficient communication transform so if
you want help out with that that would
be great but the actual down sampling
hardly takes any time at all and so I
think there's this can scale quite well
and we'll see some very nice results so
that's an example let's see if you want
to see more JavaScript examples you can
go to the bouquet jsfiddle page and you
can see sort of what it looks like to
use bouquet as a JavaScript library
again I'm just sort of showing things
off here this is the sort of thing it
looks like right I defined some data I
define my glyph declaratively I want a
scatter of circles I give the plot some
options and then I just call this make
plot and then it shows up and so again
now I have my my plot over here that I
can interact with and I can zoom around
and all that works just fine so there's
a couple of those here that are all
available again a lot more of these
around bouquet pie data org definitely
direct everyone there for lots of
documentation we've made a really strong
push on documentation there's a very
fantastic j/s reference manual there's a
much much much improved Python reference
manual so we're really making a hard
push with that this tutorial is going to
go in there as well just to look at some
of the examples in the tutorial so you
can see what's there before we wrap up
so see what these look like so here for
instance is my time series you can see
we have nice time series axes and we
pick you know we pick numbers of course
on the time series very well you know we
pick nice numbers for time series so all
that works quite well we can do that we
can look at histograms here here we see
the quad the quad glyph in action right
so we can see lots of different
instagrams but that's interesting
not sure what I did there so I've just
shown lots of different distributions
again we can style them and make them
look attractive box plots here's the
code for that so if you want to see that
here's your box plot exercise you can
work on that or take a look at the
solution as well and again there'll be
nice schema ties renders for things like
box plots coming pretty soon we just
right now we have sort of a layered
approach to taking our interface
development so we have a very low-level
interface we have this interface and
again we're going to put some schema
ties plots as well here's this
unemployment heat map you can take a
look at how to create that it's actually
you know you can see it's not a ton of
code there's a lot of comments in here
some styling but then mostly I just
splatter some rectangles over this data
that I've downloaded from the Bureau of
Labor Statistics bar charts so
interesting here's my lame is chart
again not a whole lot of code to
generate this and again there's a hover
tool for this you can put whatever data
you want in there you know right now it
just shows sort of the accountant and
the two names but you could imagine
having other data that you've inserted
and that you look at so like I said the
good news is you know way too much
content and the better news is that you
can sort of work through that at your
leisure I know there are a couple of
issues with working on this in the
notebook I said I apologize for not
having notebooks prepared in time for
you to work with directly I think that
did run into a bug with executing the
hold command twice so we'll take a look
at that if you guys want to work on
bouquet stuff I'm here for the rest of
the weekend and I'm happy to look at
stuff or answer questions so please come
find me and any other last I think we
have probably not any time any last
questions before we before we take off
ok a lot ok one
depending on what you want to do I think
it could already be and so we can have a
discussion about you know what kind of
features you want to use I mean it
depends on what what kind of thought you
want to create and what kind of features
you want to use so we should talk about
like your specific use cases there are
some places where it's going to be very
rock solid and there's a couple places
are a little bit new and we're still
working out a few kinks but I think the
0.5 release is going to be very exciting
release its again its end of April it
should be a lot of things fixed yeah
question over here someone ok last
question oh oh oh ok ok I will make sure
to put up new versions of the tar balls
and have them I did create the tar balls
at about 3 o'clock last night so
apparently that was my downfall
some of them actually download data from
the internet and some of them use data
that they read but I'll make sure to put
up a new version of tar ball so you can
just hit that same URL I would say a
couple hours later today and it'll have
a new tar ball up with the data director
in there apologies for that ok that's it